ask your Crusher to the cemetery and
sniff your dead daughter's dresses
because we have the biggest caper to
Star Christian Bale since I'm Batman
Netflix's the pale blue eye is a
historical murder mystery that'll have
you like
okay maybe not that frustrated but you
get the gist in this video we'll be
taking a look at the films ending the
clues leading to the Killer and of
course its big twists so strap on in and
be sure to like And subscribe because I
may not always cover the shows you're
watching but when I do it's pretty cool
meet investigator Augustus land are
renowned for his work solving some of
New York's most difficult crimes he's
been called to West Point Military
Academy to solve a most gruesome murder
the hanging of a young Cadet who's found
with his heart missing this poor guy is
Cadet Leroy Frye the first in a series
of grisly murders that Landor is tasked
with solving along the way Landor
employs the help of a young Edgar Allan
Poe yes the famous poet but
unfortunately since this film and the
book it's based off is historical
fiction none of this really happened
there is some measure of historical
accuracy as Poe did attend West Point
for a brief period but fortunately for
him he was never nearly sacrificed in
his Panic ritual early on we get our
first suspect Dr Marquis the man in
charge of Performing the autopsy on Mr
fraud it's deduced that the heart was
taken out by someone who was good with a
knife and had a basic understanding of
human anatomy but what's more concerning
were all the details the doctor missed
for example the contusion found on the
back of Mr Fry's head or torn note
clutched between his fingers both of
these pointing to the theory that Mr Fry
did not hang himself rather was killed
was the doctor merely incompetent in his
analysis of Mr Fry or is something more
nefarious at play when Landor discovers
that the murder may have been the result
of a Satanic ritual he visits friend and
expert of the occult Jean Pepe there he
learns of a witch hunter by the name of
ongri Le clerc who left behind
instructions on achieving immortality he
would have known that at a witch's Feast
they dined on unclean animals hearts of
unbaptized children and the hearts of
hanged men perhaps hard parts were
pivotal in a ritual which would give
this immortality in an effort to gain
more clues Poe infiltrates Fry's friend
group which includes three men of
importance Randy Ballinger Stoddard and
Artemis Marquis the doctor's son soon
he's invited over to the Marquis
household where he meets Artemis sister
Leah whom he falls in love with but
Randy isn't too fond of Poe's admiration
for Leah and attacks him at night with
Landor saving the day and fending off
the attack the next morning however
Randy is found hung with his heart out
just like Cadet fry Poe and Landor are
invited over to the Marquis home to
mourn the death of Randy they are Lander
finds a few items of note an odd looking
Tome a painting which we'll later learn
is that of which Hunter Henry Leclerc
and a West Point officer's jacket one
which is missing the bars on its
shoulder if you remember one of the
privates who was on guard the night of
Fry's murder remembers being relieved by
an officer who had these bars removed
with this Landor deduces that Artemis
the only Marquis family member able to
wear this jacket and pull off being an
officer is likely the killer using the
killings as some sort of Satanic ritual
to save his ailing sister well it turns
out the entire family is in on it Leah
has suffered from life-threatening
seizures her entire life and she told
her family that she could hear the voice
of angry the clerk he would tell her how
to cure her and Achieve immortality now
Dr Marquis had tried to help his
daughter his entire life but to no avail
and thus he was willing to indulge her
in these occult dealings if it would
mean her getting better and according to
him Leah started to get better
furthermore Leah and Artemis promised
their father that Cadet fry was already
dead when they got to him so why not
take out his heart and use it for this
experiment this is why the doctor did
such sloppy work on the autopsy he was
merely trying to cover up for his
children even Mrs fry played by Gillian
Anderson is in on the whole ritual too
the doctor says this experiment worked
for a time but his daughter's ill
illness came back hence why they needed
more Hearts unfortunately Poe was taken
as their next victim and it's up to land
or to save the day but the ritual goes
horribly awry when the building catches
on fire and Leah and Artemis are killed
by a falling beam now you think this
would be the end of the story The
murderers are killed Dr Marquis loses
his job and Mrs Marquis her two children
once again the incomparable Augustus
slander has solved the case that is if
it weren't for the clever Ingenuity of
Edgar Allan Poe earlier in the film Poe
received a letter from Landor and he
noticed something peculiar the
handwriting on it matched that of the
note clutched in the hand of Cadet fry
surely Landor didn't have anything to do
with the murders that is until Poe puts
the pieces of the puzzle together first
he found out about the death of landor's
daughter from Patsy a prostitute land or
slept with and confided in turns out
Lander's daughter Matilda committed
suicide after she was brutally raped by
three West Point Cadets additionally po
found Fry's necklace it may also be a
dog tag and one of Matilda's poetry
books in landor's Cabin a necklace with
the initials LF for Leroy Frye in an act
of Revenge Landor wrote a fake letter to
fry posing as Patsy in the film it's
believed that this letter was actually
written by Leah but when fry arrives at
the location he calls out for Patsy
implying he has some sort of
relationship with this prostitute this
allowed Landor to lure fry to a secluded
location murder him but while he was
stringing him up he's nearly discovered
and has to flee the body is later
discovered and taken back to the academy
where Leah and Artemis snatch out the
heart this still leaves two other men
who defiled his daughter Landor
discovered that man number two was Randy
Ballinger after he read Fry's Journal he
killed Randy and made the body look as
though it was mutilated by satanists the
third man was Stoddard who fled from the
academy after he knew someone was
killing those responsible for Matilda's
according to Landor he he never killed
Stoddard saying that living the rest of
your life looking over your shoulder is
a fate worse than death upon repeat
viewings you can see the director has
left breadcrumbs that hint Landor is the
killer for example the first shot of him
is washing the blood off of his
truncheon Leroy Fry's blood when he's
asked to come to West Point to see the
superintendent he asks and if I should
decide not to come
thinks he could be found out the title
of the movie is the pale blue eye which
is a line from pose The Telltale Heart
in fact Poe recites a line from it in
the movie in the story The narrator
describes an old man with a pale blue
eye that makes the narrator go mad
resulting in him killing the old man and
taking out his heart Landor is similar
to this narrator in that he too is
driven by an urge to kill this urge is
driven by revenge and just like in the
story once the deed is done it will not
relieve him of his pain no matter what
land or does it will not bring his
daughter back in Poe's first meeting
with Landor Poe informs him the killer
must be a poet not an actual poet but
metaphorically someone who works with
symbols and what stronger symbol is
there than the heart the men who killed
his daughter took away his heart so to
speak his love and joy now Poe has
evidence that could put Landor away for
good but instead of turning him in he
burns it perhaps he knows that land or
won't kill again that the suffering he's
faced so far is prison enough as is the
last shot is of Landor on the same Cliff
his daughter committed suicide he lets
go of his daughter's cloth a metaphor
for letting go and coming to terms with
her loss it's left ambiguous whether or
not he jumps off to join her but I tend
to believe he didn't as director Scott
Cooper tells Netflix I think Landor has
finally come to terms with the loss of
his daughter and I think he's mimicking
in her footsteps but I think he
ultimately realizes there's more to life
but what did you think did Landor
plummet to his death to join his
daughter or did he finally let go I want
to hear your thoughts and theories in
the comments below thanks for watching
everyone be sure to like And subscribe
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on Twitter and Instagram at thinkstory
YT until next time remember
foreign